I'm really happy to be here I spent many
happy hours in this building some in the
chairs you're sitting in a couple of
times before speaking when Terry was
running or began this seminar and many
more hours with Manish and many other
colleagues and students upstairs
so as Manish said I'm going to talk a
bit about this book I've written it
doesn't capture everything I've done but
the things that I've done about space
it's cheap so I never under $20 so and I
have way too much to tell you and I'm
gonna try to tell you too much
so all creatures must move an act in
space to survive so this is a small baby
the baby doesn't yet talk the baby has
learned an enormous amount and the baby
has solved many many problems without
language and these are great apes and I
could say a similar thing they don't
speak they gesture a bit they cry but
languages we know it they don't have and
yet they solve many intricate problems
they can do rudimentary math they can
tell the difference between 80 things
and 85 things without counting so all
creatures must move an act you know in
space in order to survive and even
plants need to be able to move towards
the Sun away from the wind in order to
survive so my thesis rather audacious in
this book is that all sort begins a
special sort what spatial sort it's
moving and interacting in space with the
things in it so spatial thinking is the
foundation of thought not the entire
edifice I like language I don't allowed
but the foundation so some of the
argument comes from the recent work that
or the work that it's not some of it
isn't reason that won the Nobel Prize
from the journal creeps laboratory and
the Mosers they hooked up electrodes to
rats running around an environment in
single cells and found that different
places when the rat was in different
places it ignited specific cells so one
of them is up there the rat moves here
that cell fires the rat moves here
another cell fires they wrote a book ok
for NATO saying this was a cognitive map
the problem was it wasn't a map those
spatial cells those place cells weren't
displayed spatially so the Mosers
working in O'Keefe's lab both postdocs
found a place where this the cells our
raids spatially in internal cortex one
synapse away so these were called grid
cells and recent work and they're
created by the movement of the rat the
rat has to be moving is keeping track of
the movement and the orientation of the
head and so they're established by
movement recent work with human beings
implanting single cells in in
hippocampus and internal cortex which is
done sometimes before epilepsy surgery
so recent work on human beings has found
that these single cells in hippocampus
fire for events people and ideas not
just places they gather information from
all over the cortex they're multimodal
and in encapsulate them in a single cell
what's more they're arrayed in grid
cells so grid cells are a conceptual
information temporal information and
event information so that makes the case
very strongly that spatial thinking is
this
is the foundation of all thought the
same grain structures that are that are
representing space locations in space
are also representing conceptual and
temporal and social relations
so I met afore I use and I checked this
with my hippocampal friends and nobody
screamed is that the hippocampus creates
checkers for ideas or people or events
and the grid cells are like are like a
checkerboard and they array them in
these spatial or conceptual or temporal
spaces what's more they can be erased so
the grid cells are constantly being
rewritten as infrared they were active
okay so the space is the book this is
the cavora I didn't design the cover but
I'm fond of the design partly because
some people see a man running and some
people see a network and it's meant to
be both so it's a little bit do you see
the forest or are there trees and these
are some of their topics that I cover I
talk about and I'll give you capsules of
these the spaces we act in I just gave
you brain abilities I won't give you
perspective is key just your language
cognitive tools creativity the design of
the world so before I get into tiny
tidbits of each of these I want to show
you some people thinking you're going to
get to watch thought in action so we
bring people into into the laboratory we
close the door so they're alone they're
going to be reading a description of a
space it's a complicated description
locating eight or four landmarks in a
special array is hard and they're going
to be tested okay so they study very
hard these are students they know how to
study so this is a bit of one of them
Edna's a charming town nestled in an
attractive Valley entered on River
Highway River Highway runs east-west
at the southern border of the town of
Etna toward the eastern border River
highway intersects with Mountain Road
which runs north of it so you get the
idea and you won't be tested so here is
one woman and so watch her she's reading
that description and watch her hands
she's not watching her hands
so I think you can see she's making a
man she's making lines for the pass and
she's poking dots for the places and 75%
of our participants do this and when
they do it they remember better they
perform better on the test and if we
tell them to sit I'm sorry
oh no they aren't primed at all to do it
we don't tell them in fact if you tell
people to gesture it's mixed so as I
said 75% of the people do it when they
do it they do better they're on the task
and if we tell them to sit on their
hands they do worse and some of them say
I can't think without my hands so I'm
gonna continue in this one I will show
you one more way by now done this with
all kinds of stimuli it works best with
spatial environments and with mechanical
systems you had a question sometimes
people talk to themselves sometimes not
it's it really varies and there are
people that don't gesture and do fine
but you know anytime you study people
you get variability you care in point
people do the strangest things so this
person is reading a description of how a
car brake works it's again hard they get
to read it four times so from the brake
fluid reservoir brake fluid enters and
travels sideways and down there too it's
the brake fluid accumulates it's about
them they're two pressure is exerted on
the small Pistons inside the wheel
cylinders this causes the Pistons to
move outward toward the brake drum it's
hard for me to read it without gesturing
so it will watch him and hope he comes
up he's just great there there yeah he's
a dancer so you can watch him he's
trying to figure out the car brake and
you
seem kind of reading testing reading
testing I mean as I say you're watching
someone think that's not a gesture okay
so you got it okay and now I'll go back
to the other so the gesture is a model
the situation described in the tech text
they and the models are special motor
they aren't visual they aren't looking
at their hands preventing the gesture
reduces comprehension and we get the
feeling watching them that the gestures
are translating the language into
thought by creating a model the language
itself is is arbitrary if that were in
Chinese it would look very different
we've also looked at gestures for others
and I'll tell you one study of many we
students watched an explanation of how a
car engine works and half of them
watched one video half the other one
video use gestures that showed structure
the shapes of the parts we didn't think
that would have an effect because that
kind of information is easy the other
one showed action an action is really
hard for people to get you and that's a
longer story again they were tested they
could see these videos four times they
were tested true false questions on
structure and action they made a video
explanation of the engine and they also
made a visual explanation of the engine
so what we found was they the people who
watched action gestures got more action
questions correct but what was more
striking to us is they really
incorporated the action just for
seeing the gestures the the text was the
same but just from their gestures there
was more action in their visual
explanations there were more action
gestures the gestures weren't invented
they weren't the ones they saw for the
most part and they used more action
words even though they hadn't seen more
action heard more action words so this
is a visual explanation from someone who
saw structural gestures can same text
another one this is someone who saw
action gestures and you see much more
action there there are arrows we counted
arrows many more arrows you have that
explosion there and you have bubbles
there so there were many more depictions
of action just from seeing the gesture
so seeing those action gestures made
them understand the action in a much
deeper way here's another one they also
got the stages more clearly because the
stages are distinguished by actions so
gestures and graphics gestures are both
are a more direct expression of thoughts
and language which is pretty arbitrary
gestures are actions so they're
especially good for actions however
they're fleeting graphics are static and
they stay around for you to think about
and inspect and maybe change so gestures
are for here and now and as I said there
are great apes that use gestures mostly
for sex but they use them okay
graphics are for other eyes and other
times so they're in some sense the first
solid red evidence for symbolic thinking
and people we don't know when language
evolved but we can see when people
started putting their mind in the world
I'll get to that in a second I'm I'm
already gonna see that I'm gonna have to
skip stuff okay
so space is special it's so promoter
it's kind of the confluence of vision
but blind people can have really good
spatial cognition so you get it from
hearing from smell from kinesthetic
where there's wind what pavement feels
like all of these are cues that behind
people use but it's a confluence of many
senses it's essential for survival if we
didn't know how to get home or get food
in our mouths
we'd be dependent on people forever it's
the basis for other knowledge you
already see it's not like geometry or
physical measurement our mental
representations of this basis that we
act in arson distorted and they're
distorted by our action and our
perception we live in many spaces and we
create many spaces by our actions and
for them so the space of the body I'm
going really fast over the space of the
body here a function or action Trump's
size so our representations of bodies
you can see from children's drawings
they're the same all over the world big
heads big hands and the brain the brain
exaggerated the places in our bodies
that are important for our action and
shrinks the ones that are less important
so the space of the body is is distorted
in that way around our actions the space
around the body here we've looked at
what kinds of reference frames people
use to to to understand the world around
them and they understand they use their
own body axes and gravity and again
gravity affects our actions enormous Lee
and the way things work the body axes
are by the asymmetry head feet is more
essential for keeping things in mind
then then left right it had feed in
front back so it's again a longer story
space of exploration a remarkable feat
of the human mind and also we saw of the
rats mind is to experience a world from
exploration and create a map of it
that's is it from an overview so we
experience the world as we see it and
move through it but we are able to
create a mental representation of a
larger space one that we can't see from
one place in our minds so this strikes
me as a remarkable feat of human being
and we talk about the embedded rule to
one where we're walking through it as a
route and the overview as a survey and
human beings can switch back and forth
something we've studied and others and
when we talk we tend to mix those
perspectives so perspective is a key
issue it's a spatial concept is the key
issue everywhere and one part of it is
whether we're seeing the world from our
point of view egocentric or allocentric
from above but another is whose
perspective are we taking mine or yours
and some work with Brigitte Martin Hart
showed that when this is her husband
Patrick and when action is involved we
automatically take the perspective of
the other who were more likely to take
the perspective of the other than our
own so if we tell people where is the
bottle with risk
where did where did Patrick put the book
with respect to the bottle and I'm
standing next to you asking that
question so from our point of view is
about bottles on the left but people
answer from Patrick's point of view and
say on the right and if we make them
take their own point of view it takes
them longer so when we see action we're
inclined to take the perspective of the
actor perhaps to understand the action
perhaps to prepare our own this is he
gonna throw the book at us
or is he gonna give it to us we have to
prepare our own so perspective-taking
turns out
to underlie and I'm not going to be able
to go through this
the underlies empathy certainly
problem-solving prediction and
creativity we found that when we ask
people to think of new uses for old
objects a common creativity task they're
really good at it when we ask them to
adopt different roles of different
people the space of exploration is full
of distortions and we group things
hierarchically we use landmarks as
landmarks and things get drawn into
landmarks so people think that jacque's
house is closer to the Eiffel Tower than
the Eiffel Tower to Jack's house
perspective I just told you about their
whole range of ways that we construct
the space that we explore and it's full
of distortions so we liken that to a
collage it's not coherent in two
dimensions or even three not a mental
map and each of these distortions of
space has a parallel distortion in
social judgments in temporal judgments
and conceptual judgments something I
won't be able to go through suggesting
that maybe all judgments are cognitive
collages we just gather information from
all over how we gather it depends and we
try to make something coherent or
something reasonable from this collage
of information social spaces so anyone
who's observant about ourselves and
about babies can't help but notice that
we spend an enormous amount of time
playing games that don't involve the
language that our social games from
rolling a ball with a baby back and
forth teaching turn taking and Trust to
basketball this which is incredibly
complicated and we're doing those
actions or the good players in split
seconds so why are we spending so much
time playing these social interaction
games that don't involve language even
Scrabble it's about words but the way we
communicate is by making a word we don't
say so that okay so then there are the
spaces we create in the mind and gesture
on a page in the world in words on the
page so a bit on language our minds go
from thought to thought the way our feet
go from place to place we saw that in a
place in the grid cells and we talk
about actions and thought in the ways
that we talk about in the in the ways
that our hands act down objects so
splitting hands and feet we raise ideas
pull them together tear them apart turn
them upside down push them forward toss
them out now like often Johnson
presented these as metaphors but I don't
know if there's metaphors we have no
other way about of talking about action
some thought except these ways so I
think therein we internalize the actions
and then use them on these thoughts that
we objectify or reapply there are
metaphorical uses all over the place we
talk about being out of depth the top of
the class feeling up falling into a
depression these are all explicated with
gesture - we've grown closer grown far
apart so those actions on objects get
turned into gestures on thought we put
the world in the mind I just talked
about that now I'm going to talk a
little bit about putting the mind into
the world and we do that to enhance our
physical lives but we do I'm gonna talk
about the ways where you put salt in the
world to enhance our cognitive lives our
cognitive tools can inform and educate
they can augment memory and information
processing by also dignity to something
out there they use space to represent
literal and metaphorical action
they promote inference and discovery
because I can look at the page and think
about it I don't have to keep the page
in mind anything they allow their public
so they allow creation revision and
inference by a community and I put forth
their uniquely human nobody's seen a
great a make a map in this and now I'm
open to other examples I'd be very
interested and as I said they're the
earliest evidence of symbolic thought so
let's look now at some of the ways that
people put thought in the world this is
the former oldest map and if you still
hook at websites you're going to get
this one note that there are two
perspectives it's a big stone that's why
it survived from Babylonia and there
it's representing the overview the
passing frontal views of the landmarks
so it's mixing perspectives which is
extremely common even though the
linguists and the geographers say we
shouldn't lead and the psychologists we
shouldn't be doing that this is the
current the oldest map it's about two
inches by one inch so it's very small it
would fit in your pocket it was found
not long ago in a cave in Spain so it's
very enlarged it goes back thirteen
thousand years it it again shows the in
the past and the landmarks at the same
time and it it it depicts the scene
outside the cave so can you imagine
being an archaeologist walking in this
cave picking up this small stone and
seeing it's a map of the place we're in
and how exciting that would be so space
we also show this there were also
ancient examples of the space of the
skies this one is actually showing it's
going back what five thousand years and
it's showing an asteroid entering the
the skies it's something we wouldn't
notice without a telescope anymore
because we can't see stars anymore
these are eskimo coastal maps they're
small they fit in a mitten and they show
the outline of the coast these are four
canoeists that go up and down the coast
so they can be explored with their hand
instead of their eyes and if they fall
out of the boat they float more floating
maps this is South Sea Islanders the
bamboo strips of the ocean currents the
shells are the islands they can't be
seen one from another
but people learned how to navigate with
these also using Stars and flotsam and
jetsam the ocean and at least some of
them got back okay more Maps hands this
was used by North Coast Indians to show
the major cities anyone from Michigan
holds upper hand and to show where they
live this is a New York or example okay
so we have space of the world around us
of the Stars time events this is Chauvet
and it's showing animals it's people in
not here but in others and this is
probably a stampede that it's showing
this is what's called newspaper rockets
somewhere in Utah a whole set of
petroglyphs and again showing a hunting
scene you can see stick figures with
their bows and arrows and the animals
they're hunting this is another
celestial event it is a petroglyph
here's the petroglyph here's a drawing
of it it was found in Kashmir in an
Indian astronomer recent that they was
dated recently and an Indian some
astronomer showed so why are there two
suns the Indian astronomer showed that
there was a supernova on that day or on
that date and it was a striking enough
event that somebody took the trouble of
carving it into a petroglyph and and
keeping it there for the future so we
have events people objects things this
is how to make bread it's in an Egyptian
tomb
you wonder what is doing there time
calendars for many different cultures
some are circular that's a story I could
tell some some are more linear like all
of the calendars that we use tallies
one-to-one correspondence is so
rudimentary math more sophisticated
counting some people use more than their
10 fingers to count they were much
cleverer than we Peruvian people for
counting abacus so ancient graphics show
people animals things place in
space-time and events and number again
this rudimentary number one to one
correspondence is modern graphics show
the same things and these are things
that must be important to people and in
fact the brain takes a special note of
them okay so that's ancient depictions
ancient ways of putting things are
minding of the world I'm going to show
you some more contemporary ones more or
less my modern graphics sort of began
with the Enlightenment and Diderot was
one of the first this is d the world may
have an encyclopedia of all things
including the mind he has a the
beginning has has a network of faculties
of the mind
an early cognitive scientist so here he
is teaching people what a diagram is
people would have seen depictions of
scenes like at the top that's a factory
making pins that would be familiar to
people the diagrammatic part wouldn't be
so he's got the top part in a box the
bottom part in a box separating them the
bottom part is a catalogue of the
instruments used above is something
familiar to us but in the sizes don't
correspond to the sizes of the actual
sizes the sizes are distorted so you can
see them to lighting you can see at the
top is normal lighting they all have
that
kind of lighting just the way Vermeer
used one window with lighting and the
shadows and the lighting is the way
natural light would fall or the way that
the etch or thought natural light would
fall the lighting here is to accentuate
the three dimensionality so it's using
the features that we normally associate
with scenes it's using them in different
ways in order to communicate better so
things are lined up in rows and columns
not the way they're used so this is an
early diagram that's teaching what a
diagram is this is an 18th century graph
and it's showing balance of payment it's
plotting balance of payment over time
and somebody looked at all the graphs
this is already 20 years old in both
scientific journals and places like The
Economist and USA Today and found that
75% of them are plotting one or two
variables against time which is again
the the early uses of it so I'm going to
skip that because you've seen it this is
work with Manish other ways that
diagrams are used visual instructions to
show you how to put a TV card together
this is what our high specialist
produced and this is what mination his
team turned into an algorithm where each
there it's using the cognitive design
principles that we uncovered through the
psychological research - and the design
principles are show each step in each
new part is a new step show the
perspective of action and embellish with
guidelines and arrows and this could be
an explanation for a car engine you'd
want to follow the same principles other
ways of using graphics comics I'm a big
fan of comics not so much the the
subject matter is the way they use the
visuals so this is using space and time
together and that's something quite
common you
the time in the in the window is going
left to right and talked about him and
superimpose on this space there is a map
in the Mayan codices that did something
similar so it's a natural way to see
very going drawing spatial analogies to
tell you about acceleration Harold and
the Purple Crayon telling drawing his
own story for those of you know the book
and Steinberg again using sort of
metaphor work or humorous ways of using
space so good graphic schema ties how
are we doing on time they eliminate the
irrelevant and exaggerate the essential
they show multiple perspectives this
London Tube map does not but you saw
plenty of examples they do and they're
multimodal they have symbols and
language in addition to the visuals they
use spatial relations and marks and
elements in ways that convey meaning
directory in again in contrast to
language so proximity and space
signifies proximity on an abstract
dimension we've grown closer or grown
apart centrality is centrality and
directionality the vertical is loaded
again because of gravity so it takes
power and resources and health to go up
so just about everything good goes up
horizontal seems to be more or less
arbitrary there's nothing in the world
that captures that but our weak cultural
our cultural artifacts or our cultural
customs do so reading and writing order
and also order of math and they don't
always agree so and again there are
parallels in language and gesture I'm
going to I'm going to adjust your events
in time along a horizontal line from my
right from my left to right I just did
of the opposite for you
centrality we asked people to make their
social networks and of course they're in
the middle gravity we looked at at
diagrams for evolution and geological
ages and all the introductory texts we
could find in the library and the
present time man it's always man
is always at the top because that's the
best okay
so horizontal use of space
writing order correlates with a number
line with agency in power I'll give you
some examples with speed with his
aesthetics and value seems to go with
handedness it's the only thing that goes
with handedness and it also goes with
reading order so power we have Adam on
the left and Eve on the right this is
quite common in in pictures and in fact
there was some I saw an exhibit at the
British Museum once of or of art in
India and when the language shifted from
left to right to right to left the
painting shifted okay all of a sudden
the Maharaja is not running from left to
right he's running from right to left
with his harem chasing after him but it
shifts when the language direction
shifts so this is soccer goals we we see
motion going and reading order is more
forceful violent and beautiful and in
fact more fouls are called when the from
the referees point of view the ball is
going opposite reading order so nobody's
tested that yet in in Israel or one of
the Arab countries they need to so the
butt of jokes nothing is left nothing is
right elements so we can have elements
that we talked about the meaningful use
of space now the meaningful use of
elements and I'm going to argue that
they communicate quite directly they can
be iconic so they look like what they're
representing metaphoric like scales of
justice and meaningful marks which is
without dwelling
and symbolic so a symbolic we have the
meaningful marks we have dots I don't
know the life that one got truncated we
have just indicate places or ideas as
they do in the brain and lines indicate
paths between ideas so relations arrows
are asymmetric relations and containers
can either be something like a set or an
area or a box as Diderot used it and I'm
not going to be able to talk about all
of these but there are shared meanings
that for these four dots and lines and
boxes and arrows and we looked at that
in a variety of experiments looked at
the shared meanings by presenting the
visuals and asking people to interpret
them or by presenting something in
language and asking people to construct
a visual and when you get the same thing
you can say the meaning is shared so we
looked yet with Jeff Sachs we looked at
at inferences from from graphs we gave
people one of those graphs either a B or
we labeled them with the height of kids
18 12 a height of men and women so they
only saw one and they were asked to
interpret it and our idea was that bars
separate they contain and separate so
they say there are more B's then A's or
B's are greater than A's but they they
don't imply a relationship a line
implies a relationship so it says a and
B share value they just share a
dimension they just have different
values on the same dimension and so we
expected people to give us discrete
comparisons here and trends with the
lines and that's in fact what happened
and if we describe trends and ask people
to create a visual we get lines if we
describe discrete in Paris comparisons
and ask people to create create a visual
we get bars
I'm gonna skip root mass but you can see
that there are lines and dot's and the
visual elements tend to be these sorts
of visual elements in in in the sketch
maps that people produce and they map
antis language so the route maps don't
aren't analog even though they could be
they were distorted in much the way
languages so just as we say turn our
take the angle of a turn aren't
specifying they're often not right and
the curvature is either it's straight or
curved it's discrete
so you either go down a straight path or
you go around when it's curved so we
found that these descriptive and
depictive elements are parallel
suggesting the same underlying
representation and when you think about
it the brain doesn't have words doesn't
have propositions doesn't have images
that has neurons and glia and all kinds
of other things that are affecting our
thinking so the representation that
generates either pictures or language
seems to be the same so I showed you
that they were you saw that these
schematic Maps this is how to get to
Taco Bell from one of the dorms and it's
making right angles where there are none
if the distances are way off so why do
they work they walk because of context
language to works in a context we have a
mutual understanding for interpreting
our language and a sketch map is also
going to work in a context and if I come
to a fork in the road and I think it's a
right angle but it's not I'm not going
to make a right angle with my car I'm
gonna drive along the road so and we
have us again similar understandings so
this yielded cognitive design principles
and again Manish and crystal tey took
over that paths and nodes are important
but distances
and exact directions aren't so instead
of this as years ago none of you
remember this or so only some of you
these are the maps you used to get from
websites and they don't tell you how to
get on and off the highway the
information you need isn't there it's
cluttered by all kinds of irrelevant
information and these are the first pass
of the maps that the nation Chris
produced and they were loved for good
reason and it just shows you what I love
about engineers you know we do research
engineers gather and distill information
from so many different places and
produce a tool that we can use okay we
get similar things in gesture pointing
to landmarks tracing paths endings
what's interesting about gesture is they
make a narrative about it it's got a
beginning middle and in arrows and then
I'm gonna really jump so aerials are
interesting partly they don't seem to
appear before their 20th century and I
I'd be eager for someone to find
examples early examples of errors you do
have hands and fingers and even feet
there's a lovely petroglyph in Ephesus
with feet telling you how to get to the
brothel it's bringing you there so there
are the arrow like things but arrows per
say I don't think anyone's found one
before their 20th century so they have a
sort of natural interpretation in that
the erosion lines look arrow like and of
course arrows that fly but they have
many uses so this is work with Julie
Heiser we gave people one of these
drawings one of these diagrams either
with or without arrows and asked them
tell us tell me what it's conveying and
we found that without arrows we got
structural descriptions people told us
where the parts were in relation to each
other so you couldn't tell it by the
language they were is us or hazards
and with arrows we suddenly got
step-by-step beginning to end functional
action descriptions and again active
verbs so it was unambiguous how we coded
them the URLs change the meaning then we
gave another group of people either a
structural description or an action
description and asked them to produce a
diagram and again this is very typical
so they drew these diagrams just from
the descriptions it's pretty good but
you can see from a structural
description they label the parts when we
gave them an action functional
description they don't label the parts
even though they were labeled in the
description but they give us arrows
indicating the action so arrows convey
meaning they change something from
structure to action the trouble with
arrows is since they have many meanings
Bob Horn whom you may know cuz he spoke
here many years ago and was very
interested in visual language he came up
with a hundred and seven that seems too
many so but you can get seven or eight
they can point connect they can indicate
the temple next step they can indicate
causality they can show movement
direction manner of movement wavy arrows
staccato arrows they can indicate
increases/decreases they can indicate
invisible forces so these were very
common in World War two and the arrows
are being used they're color-coded by
the side of the war and they're the
width is indicating the number of troops
and the direction is where the troops
are moving these are pretty standard and
comprehensible we looked at the diagrams
in stem books I have I have those
diagrams if somebody wants them we
analyze what kinds of diagrams are used
in stem books so this one is is foreign
DNA entering cells it uses arrows and
three different meanings without
disambiguating so this is hard for
students I mean I could figure it
I'm no expert in this but there are
cases where so these are labeling trench
and open foreign DNA the foreign DNA is
entering that's movement this arrow is
the next step so it's being used to
label indicate movement and the next
temple step without really
disambiguating again the context was
sufficient for me to figure it out I
worry about other people and then you
get beautiful things like the rock cycle
and you know the geologists will say
what's the problem and then I say what
does this arrow mean what does that
arrow mean and they say oops so even
they can't interpret and I have plenty
of examples of them where they're
beautiful but in even abstract ones they
all sound disambiguated here if you've
been to Venice you know you encounter
this kind of situation very frequently
were they always pointed those
directions this is how to pass a bill in
Congress right you go in circles okay so
these schematic elements are like
schematic spatial terms point is a place
or an idea line is a path or a relation
and arrow and like spatial term so it
becomes a visual vocabulary for diagrams
you can create diagrams out of these and
having the iconic ones and again they're
they're schematic and the context is
going to disambiguate is it a romantic
relationship or a mathematical
relationship again the context
presumably will tell me
so Steinberg got there first lines have
many meanings here's the this is
wall-sized and they're Steinberg drawing
and it's the grand canal and a
clothesline and the sidewalk from above
in the Nile in the top of a railroad
bridge and so on but you're not even
aware of it it's the same line because
you quickly interpret it so neat lines
are great for getting you from A to B or
telling you how
a car break works but then there are
messy lines and this is Gary and this is
a drawing that he made and we started
studying messy lines this is work with
Misaka Misaka sewer we looked at
architects and we gave them in an
assignment to make a museum with certain
constraints and they make discoveries in
their sketches and it's exactly the
ambiguity that allows them to
reconfigure and make and make new
discoveries artists do the same this is
a graduate student former graduate
student fine artist who studied artists
and they they can't talk while they're
drawing same with the architect's
language interferes it's the
conversation between the eye and the
hand and the page and artists say the
ideas emerge from the page so I'm gonna
skip here this is using diagrams for
inference we've shown that diagrams
promote collaboration and now I'm gonna
try to end so this is the world that
nature gives us it's pretty messy and in
fact messy desks promote new ideas this
is the world redesign so how do we
design the world we put the mind into
the world one prominent way we organize
our lives is around themes we put all
the things that belong for cleaning and
the bathroom all the things that belong
for cooking in the kitchen and so forth
so we gather many different kinds of
things put them in the same place
because they're going to be used
together
I call them themes we also have
categories of things and our categories
go on shelves so we put our plates small
plates here our bowls here our cups
there and again we're organizing them
into categories and hierarchies of
categories in our homes and in the
supermarket and we on our bookshelves
orders our books might be ordered by
topics they might be ordered by size
but we get orders in there so again this
is fruit and vegetable stand categories
hierarchies lines boxes the world is
organized that way lines and rows and
columns and boxes in 3d assembly lines
one-to-one correspondence is this
beginning to sound like programming
one-to-one correspondences repetitions
cycles embeddings in our place settings
and kids grow up witness there's so much
intelligence around us the caves didn't
have so much
similarly here repetitions symmetry
embedding we use those patterns which
catch the eye because they're gorgeous
dots we use those patterns deliberately
in our visualizations so the periodic
table of train schedules bar charts this
is a likelihood of a computer issue
being solved by reconfiguring reimaging
anti-virus uninstalling other or turning
it on and off okay and this is the
amount of time it took me to draw each
bar so I introduced the concept of
fraction it's a contraction and it's an
ugly word all my innate words are ugly
it's a contraction of space action and
abstraction and the ideas actions and
space create abstractions you just saw a
bunch of them those actions get
internalized and re externalizes
gestures as actions on thought and the
patterns get used and externalize as
communications as diagrams so this is
fraction is a kind of cycle we can enter
at any point linking space action
abstraction so we not only put our minds
in the world we designed the world and
we saw that but we not only design the
world we diagram the world so the world
is a diagram and with that I end
[Applause]
so out of time I don't know it's too
much to take in the beginning was very
filled with gestures and actions and
movements and this will thank you for
the question which also informs people
of the transition from gestural sort of
language to one that has a real syntax
and semantics so again I'm fond of
language to differentiate even
differentiate what graphics do and what
the annotation of graphics do it becomes
difficult and it's overlapping clearly
deaf people manage perfectly well
without hearing or can manage and blind
people can manage quite well without
without seeing although blind people
gesture and blind children gesture again
indicating it's for their own song and I
think they're complementing each other
and there are many cases where the
gestures are really giving me more
information than the language so if you
ask someone where to go so I was once
trying to find a store in London and I
knew you had to make two turns from
where we were to get there and I asked a
woman in a store and she said you go
straight on straight
down straight on and I said don't you
have to turn and she said yes but you
know her her head is always pointing
forward so and she doesn't know the name
of the street so for her it's straight
on straight on and if you get lost in a
foreign country and ask and you know for
words of Italian and not more you watch
the gesture and they just you know tell
you is the road curving is it going up
and down so they and that's our
canonical way of speaking is its
language grew up you and I talking or
groups talking and it was multimodal it
used the intonation of our voice which
can negate what we're saying by irony so
it human beings are remarkable in being
able to use all kinds of resources to
make meaning and some of it is we've had
experience undoubtedly making meaning in
those different ways so we can
understand things from writing but we
all know that emails get misinterpreted
and in in many ways and that watching
someone's face and seeing their gesture
and hearing their intonation what
changes so you lose something but it's
similar again in space I can blind
people manage without seeing so if some
things are complementing so I'm not
answering your question exactly
one thing that I think gestures do
really nicely that language often
forgets to do is they set up a general
schema for understanding things so
simple examples on the one hand and on
the other and then I can keep referring
to those places in space I've set them
up and I can keep referring to them and
I can even create a middle space and I'm
often doing that without saying and
you're seeing that and and getting it
from the scene so there are many studies
showing that if you take away their
gestures from an oral communication like
this you lose a lot if you take away the
language you're going to use a lot too
so that's not a direct answer
but maybe some of the nuances you were
looking for okay
and I don't hear or see so I'm coming
back to hear you vary across cultures
and because Western education and those
are good questions and the answer always
with cultural things as yes and no or
without ducation yes and no is somebody
went this is just an example somebody
went to and again gestures and diagrams
have similar visual vocabularies I hope
that was clear somebody went to New
Guinea years ago this is probably 40
years ago and their River traders that
go up and down the river they're not
literate and they're trading and they've
never seen a map they've never been in a
school and asked them to make a map and
it's a small sample so these aren't real
data they're anecdotes but they what
they drew was aligned with with circles
where they stopped so that idea that the
river is they they regular eyes to a
line it's novel line and that the stops
were these dots was something was their
way of expressing so there's going to be
some universality there's going to be
some cultural specificity either
diagrams or and those are harder and
harder to study because right okay I
think you want to end at this point yeah
I can
[Applause]